in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Justin
and merrier with us hey guys how are you
hey Dave great super excited to be here
we're honored to have you welcome
welcome where do you guys live Detroit
Michigan
very cool was that a bit of a drive or
fly down we made a trip out of it
driving down yeah that's a long drive
with three pretty ladies little pretty
ladies for pretty ladies total so tell
me your daughter's names and ages this
is Alice and she's nine
hazel seven Nora five and one on the way
oh all right very cool so how much dad
have you guys paid off one hundred and
ten thousand dollars way to go and how
long did that take 1086 agonizing days
about thirty-six months that's fabulous
and making what kind of money during
that time we started out at 80 mm and
with some raises bonuses international
pay extended business trip pay and then
some a whole lot of overtime it was up
over a hundred thousand way to go hard
work huh yeah so what kind of debt was
the 110 thousand it was our house oh you
paid off your house we did are you - I'm
39
37 and you're not even 40 and you got a
paid-for house you're officially weird
what's this house worth I've probably
around 150 160 why'd it go you guys
don't even have a house payment Wow what
in the world happened 36 months ago that
made you decide to go on this journey
well David's really it was a we had a
feeling of hopelessness you know as
followers of Christ we have hope for
eternal security but um there was a the
bottom of the housing the mortgage
crisis and our house was upside down we
we couldn't sell it if we wanted to we
couldn't refinance and you know with
some work and some paying it down we're
able to refinance and as I just continue
to stare at that mortgage payment and
the the balance you know I just got
sicker and sicker seeing it and you know
the Bible says Hope deferred makes the
heart sick and I just I felt hopeless
so we we had already gone through the
first four baby steps but gotten a
little lazy at that point so at this
point I put together some numbers and I
told Mary we could pay it off in 40
months and she she agreed to it and we
did it in 36 just under 36 way to go
very cool so Mary when you're looking at
him he's coming up with this you're
going this is doable or did you kind of
go look crazy I was excited about the
idea but I was nervous about the actual
implementation of it would you know
could we really do it could we follow
through and stick to it so how many
times did you fall off the wagon in the
36 months I don't think we did yeah I
think we met our goal every month we
were working towards you guys are very
precise people yeah something I did I I
really wanted some motivation in front
of our eyes every every day every month
every week you know as we were going
through this and so I I made a puzzle I
didn't want a giant thermometer in our
house forever yeah and I wanted this to
be a reminder for us to see as we go
through it and even when we're weird
when we're done 10 20 a hundred years
later you know the the reminder of what
we had done and so I found this great
picture it says keep out of debt and
it's engraved on a rack there's a huge
rack and so this was every piece was
about $200 and we as we paid off the
mortgage
we added pieces to the puzzle and you
know it just it helped us to stay
focused you know the big thing for me it
it reminds me in Joshua chapter 4 when
the Israelites crossed the Red Sea
across the Jordan River on dry ground
God told him take 12 rocks from the
bottom of the riverbed and set him up as
a memorial to forever be reminded of
what God did for them and it was mighty
power and and this is our memorial stone
you know we didn't do this ourselves God
helped us to do this very cool awesome
you need a little milestone there a
little marker that's good it gave our
girls something to be an active part of
of putting the puzzle together and
getting excited each month of how many
pieces we were putting on
very cool they kept us on task
we're only putting ten pieces on this
one oh that's great
so how many pieces total was it 513 okay
all right way to go that's fun that's a
good way to keep up with it without a
thermometer on the refrigerator door
yeah that's a good little deal and so
you're gonna frame that now and keep it
at your debt-free Rock yeah it's it's
hanging on the wall it will hang out we
brought it with us but we'd like to get
autograph it would be too that'll be
neat you know very fun well
congratulations you guys very well done
not even 40 in your house is paid for I
love it Justin Mary Alice hazel and Nora
Detroit Michigan a hundred and ten
thousand dollars paid off in 36 months
making eighty two to a hundred thousand
that's their last debt house and
everything count it down let's hear a
debt free scream can I say one more
things yesterday so through this process
we we wanted to make a big deal out of
it and so we went to the bank in person
to pay off the debt and we took a stack
of money you know the kids were holding
the money we got pictures of that with
pictures of them holding it and so they
could see what we were paying off what
we were accomplishing and we took a
giant check with us to the bank like a
Publishers Clearing House size check and
the kids are holding scientists say we
paid it off we paid it off on the fourth
of July or the day before the bank was
closed but independence day you know so
we go so yeah that's one was the banker
freaking out they were we gave them
advance notice than we were coming oh
that's fun all right count it down guys
let's hear your debt free scream all
right here we go three two one
yes I love it I love it I love it that's
how it's done man that's amazing